Noah Williams: Today’s focus: load testing for Black Friday.
Avery Kim: Any blockers from last time?
Jordan Patel: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Noah Williams: I think we split load testing for Black Friday into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Action: book design review.
Noah Williams: We’ll need QA test cases listed on load testing for Black Friday.
Samira López: Let’s not block on load testing for Black Friday; start with a spike.
Riley Chen: Let’s keep this within this sprint on load testing for Black Friday.
Noah Williams: Infra-wise, We need to align with capacity.
Priya Singh: Edge cases around auth and retries on load testing for Black Friday.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on load testing for Black Friday; ship a thin slice.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on load testing for Black Friday; parallelize testing.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on load testing for Black Friday; start with a spike.
Jordan Patel: Action: set up dashboards.
Jordan Patel: From QA perspective, Specifically for load testing for Black Friday.
Samira López: We should add a feature flag on load testing for Black Friday.
Riley Chen: Action: book design review.
Riley Chen: I propose we split load testing for Black Friday into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: From QA perspective, Security review is likely.
Jordan Patel: From design side, We can chunk work behind a ticket.
Samira López: Risk: scope creep for load testing for Black Friday.
Jordan Patel: Let’s clarify acceptance criteria on load testing for Black Friday.
Jordan Patel: Observability dashboards for errors on load testing for Black Friday.
Priya Singh: Action: book design review.
Samira López: Infra-wise, We might need a migration.
Samira López: I propose we split load testing for Black Friday into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: I think we split load testing for Black Friday into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: I propose we split load testing for Black Friday into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on load testing for Black Friday; start with a spike.
Samira López: Let’s not block on load testing for Black Friday; start with a spike.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on load testing for Black Friday; ship a thin slice.
Jordan Patel: I propose we split load testing for Black Friday into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: I think we split load testing for Black Friday into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: Action: create test plan.
Priya Singh: From design side, Design feedback is pending.
Noah Williams: My take is we split load testing for Black Friday into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: From QA perspective, We need to align with capacity.
Avery Kim: Infra-wise, Performance baseline needs to be recorded.
Jordan Patel: UX needs a final pass on load testing for Black Friday.
Noah Williams: Action: set up dashboards.
Noah Williams: Action: book design review.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on load testing for Black Friday; ship a thin slice.
Jordan Patel: Action: write migration.
Riley Chen: From design side, Security review is likely.
Avery Kim: From design side, We will stage it behind a feature flag.
Samira López: From QA perspective, We might need a migration.
Riley Chen: Risk: flaky tests for load testing for Black Friday.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on load testing for Black Friday; ship a thin slice.
Samira López: Let’s not block on load testing for Black Friday; ship a thin slice.
Priya Singh: From QA perspective, We can chunk work behind a ticket.
Noah Williams: Risk: scope creep for load testing for Black Friday.
Avery Kim: Okay, who can take ownership?
Avery Kim: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Riley Chen: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.